hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar laboratory medicine
what should we be measuring I am Judy
Oracle a birds and I'll be your
moderator for this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
let's get started you can pose questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green to an
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
presented a speaker bryan r jackson md
dr. Jackson is vice president and chief
medical informatics officer for a RUP
laboratories in Salt Lake City Utah his
also associate professor of pathology at
the University of Utah dr. death dr.
Jackson received his MD from the
University of Utah and completed a
clinical pathology residency at
dartmouth-hitchcock Medical Center prior
to joining a RUP and utah faculty dr.
Jackson was a clinical pathologist and
format assist at dartmouth-hitchcock
Medical Center a product manager for a
belgium-based medical software firm and
a National Library of Medicine
informatics fellow at the University of
Utah his research interests include
economic analysis of diagnostic testing
and physician utilization of laboratory
tests he is certified in clinical
pathology by the American Board of
pathology dr. Jackson will now begin his
presentation
alright thanks Judy introduction I
appreciate the opportunity to talk about
a topic this morning that I think it's
going to be a really important one
namely laboratory measure excuse me
laboratory medicine what should we be
measuring where to put it a different
way and as we enter the Accountable Care
era for value-based healthcare naughty
based medicine how do we best manage the
clinical laboratory enterprise and by
manage we're really talking a lot about
what what metrics are going we're going
to use one of what are we going to
measure my baseline assumption Flynn's
topic is in the role of the clinical
laboratory and is going to evolve needs
to evolve from running tests to having a
broader responsibilities over diagnostic
processes I'd like to frame this a
little bit historically I'm going back
about 150 100 five years to the Flex in
a report and this is a perspective I I
picked up from brett-james any of you
can know him the quality guru liniment
health care um abraham flexner was an
educator who in the early nineteen
hundreds was asked to do a comprehensive
report of american medical education and
reason for this was an American Medical
Education was real mess you know most
doctors back then about their degrees
from diploma mills there's a widely
varying quality of medical schools in
medical science medical care and in the
flex and report established that US
medical care and US medical training
needed to be science-based so this was a
really really good thing and it
positioned us for for where we are today
where healthcare is very sorry it's
based professional science based
industry but there was one downside and
that is in the all the emphasis on
science and the management side of
healthcare became sort of culture
we separated from the science to where
we've created a whole separate class of
healthcare administrators that with
different training tracks and different
professional skiers from the
practitioners of health care and that's
a little bit unfortunate i think it's
important that that those of us in the
healthcare practitioners space you know
go back to management science and look
for opportunities to to incorporate that
into to kind of running of our
laboratories i'm going to use sort of a
factory analogy i realized that this is
extremely limited that in many ways
healthcare is not like a factory and I
could go through those reasons it's a
long list but but there's some ways in
which using factory knowledge is sort of
simplifies the paradigm of thinking on
management in the healthcare space the
the key variable to were looking to
manage here in Diagnostics is the
doctors in start the 11 pairs i mighta
thought about managing doctors but
really that's what that's what we need
to do in healthcare is managed what
doctors do that doesn't mean one hundred
percent control them does it mean that
we take away all of their autonomy and
other they're intelligent decision
making it means we think about them
rationally in a management census
management managing doctors just like
managing factories is not about a
particular tool or even just a family of
tools it's not about a particular
technique our particular technology and
its really a system and the the simplest
way to represent a system and to a
biology trained audience would be in a
foreign feedback loop I'm in a
management system you need some sort of
the government structure someone needs
to be in charge or some some entity
needs to be in charge but in order to
govern you need accommodation of data
and controls I'll I'll put together
within feedback loops
this is not an unfamiliar concept to
those of us who have had a lot of
education in cellular cellular biology
for example so then the management
really does work the same way so you
management you measure and you set up
metrics on how your labs performing and
you set up controls yourself well
essentially you want to move towards
self collection that controls the
correct based on whether your lab is
operating the way you want it to or not
if I were managing a factory these are
the types of metrics that I would want
and there are a lot of them there's not
you know one single measure of whether
your factory is performing well or not
these metrics can be grouped into
categories however for convenience costs
our object on the right-hand column
costs are obviously an important part of
managing any business enterprise and
those costs need to be measured at a
very granular level so you know the cost
of every specific item that you order
every employee that that you hire but
you also need to be able to enroll those
costs up to an executive level to know
you know what the total amount of a
grown man who's your spending likewise
if you're running a factory the outcome
of interest is usually revenue and so
you need to measure that and a granular
level but also rolled up to an executive
level on the cost of revenue is not just
about the money even in a factory even
if your outcome is all about the money
running the factory is not all about the
money because if you don't have quality
you're not going to get that money so
you need to be able to measure those
those variables which link cost to
revenue variables which caused your
products to be sellable and desirable
and and so forth so you need to identify
the quality measurements that connect
those two and again measure them edit
and a frontline granular level but also
rolled up to an aggregate level to know
if your overall Carly's where is where
you want to be
far away it is so that's so sort of
think that is sort of a am a model of
measurement in it is inside so how can
we translate this into a health care
setting particularly around diagnostics
and as I said before health care is
different than a factory and so we're
going to have to adjust this a bit on
the cost category them is sort of the
easiest one to translate because they
don't laboratory obviously have cost me
since I costs we have personnel costs
and in laboratory managers today
generally do a good job are familiar
with the problems of measuring costs um
I would argue that there are some
changes that need to be made here though
in terms of ways of thinking about cost
from a health care system perspective
rather than just securely laboratory
perspective and I'll explain that in a
minute um the if you go to get to the
left hand side of the screen and let me
pull up my wife bored here so go to the
left hand side of the screen quality
measurements are obviously really
important in a healthcare setting
they're going to be different specific
measures from a factory with the
constantly measuring quality is is
understood the middle category I've
changed and that's the outcome category
in a factory setting most business
settings if you're running a factory
your outcome of interest is dollars but
it helps carrot it really isn't we pay
attention to the dollars coming in
really because we need to cover our
costs that the outcome of interest in
health care is really patient benefit if
we want to know are we succeeding is
elaborate as a clinical enterprise and
if we just say you know you're
profitable last year that's not very
satisfying but if we say that we met the
needs of the clinical enterprise to take
care patients that's really lik what we
care about
now if you look at all of these
categories costs patient benefit quality
and and granular and rolled up to the
executive level where do we have good
metrics today I would argue that we have
in most laboratory clinical laboratory
settings we have pretty good metrics in
the rolled up costs and the granular
level quality that other than those
categories I think we've got a lot of
work to do that's what I'm going to be
talking about today so the word to do is
in everything that's out else but the
world up quality measurements the
granular level costs but not from a lab
perspective from the healthcare
perspective and then all the patient
benefit measurement is is really
challenging but is something that you
can get started okay so let me start
with costs again and when you're
speaking in sort of business language
this is one of the areas that is the
easiest to relate to most laboratories
and today already have a really good
handle on and sort of traditional cost
items that from a laboratory perspective
and so you know what you're paying your
employees in labor not much agents
Constance tonight's hopefully you have a
census of the costume facilities and in
your settings but if we're going to
truly manage costs in a way and it is
integrated into value-based health care
we're going to rethink this about a bit
well we don't throw away what I already
have we have to add to it importantly we
need to know our cost per test that may
sound obvious but is a laboratory most
lab managers today think in terms of you
know I spent as much on reagents and so
the social neighbor and to really get
down to cost per test this is trickier
than it sounds you think well you take
all your labor and reagents and divide
it by the number
you're probably asleep your texts are
running multiple different tests on the
same instrument then maybe managing
multiple instruments of work that they
runs so all of your instrument overhead
all of your all your labor needs to be
allocated properly to the different
orderable tests and that's that's tricky
to do some in some hospital settings lab
managers sort of cheat and use the
hospital charge master or or Medicare
food schedules as a surrogate for what
has caused this becomes important for
example if your doctors ask you how much
does this cost sounds like an easy
question do you have an answer for them
if you just give them a Medicare
allowable amount for that test it's
going to be really biased because
Medicare fee schedules in really bias in
hospital charge masters even more biased
so this is something that takes a bit of
work once you've got cost for tests down
then you can start being that costs per
case listen even trickier because you
need to start taking into account how
many at tests of different types get
used for different types of clinical
cases in your clinical enterprise I'm is
your laboratory ever done that before I
would send in the vast majority of
settings that has not been done from in
order to do that you have to invalid
cost of the component level but the out
overhead allocation really gets tricky
and the variation in clinical care is
what gets really tricky so a heart
failure patient is not a heart failure
patient now one heart failure patient
may be really stable and need an
occasional BNP or an occasional who
knows what let's just stick with BNP
another heart failure patient that may
be really unstable and have a lot of
doctors musics and they may have a lot
more lapses so figuring out your cost
per case in terms of that testing is
really dependent on those patients are
sick they are and in the practices of
the doctors in how sort of lab heavy
they are anywhere from there
practices there's a really good article
about four years ago in the harvard
business review by robert kaplan michael
quarter now these are not physicians
these are business role types they're
actually quite famous strategy writers
in the academic business world but what
capital corner basically laid out was a
cost accounting method that could be
really useful in health care and it
really comes down to how do you estimate
you know in a rule you know a reasonably
accurate reliable fashion and the cost
per case of care and once you've
measured the cost per case and you can
know you know our hospital spends this
much on heart failure patients in the
distribution looks like this but
importantly the contribution of
laboratory testing is as much portion of
physician professional charging not
professional charges but professional
cost is as much the contribution Nursing
is as much and so forth then you can
really start to manage the components
and see where your outliers are where
your your biggest waste is etc most
hospitals have not done this I'm here at
the University of Utah may actually have
done this it's something called
value-driven outcomes and and you can
you know there's some air times articles
which describing sort of a high level
you know what we're working right here
it's a really interesting topic and been
really useful top um okay if you want if
in your laboratory setting if you want
to get make progress on measuring costs
yeah they're they're easy things to do
their hard things to do I would say that
the below us hanging fruit here is the
tracking the costs of expensive test
categories by ordering department and
physician so so you know who you know
who's ordering your 5,000 are our tests
in large valium because those are those
are the ones that really have the
fastest potential
your costs out of whack a clinical
perspective a little less looking fruit
would be to cost out your entire test
mix again don't don't start with the
chargemaster don't start with
third-party fee schedules really in
Sudan I'm not then I'm a long run it'll
be really great if we could all we can
estimate our our diagnostic testing
costs per case for different types of
diseases but that does make a lot of
work okay next category that if costs
are on the input than patient benefits
the output so how do we measure patient
benefit or how can we measure patient
have a lot of people look at national
measurement systems management national
quality measurement systems and put a
lot of expectation hope in those kinds
of systems so no heat is CMS ACL
measures you know things coming out of
the National Quality forum etc these are
measurements that the pairs are
currently using to measure equality so
hey why don't we use them as well and
and use these as a measurement of how
well we're benefiting patients and the
problem there's several problems with
these and the most obvious glaring
problem is that national invented
quality measurement systems are
essentially looking under the lamp post
for quality they're measuring things
that are the easiest and most
politically defensible to measure but
they're measuring a very very tiny
fraction of overall health care
processes so a full-service hospital
will treat hundreds of different
diseases and everyone is easy is going
to have a wide range of white variation
patients that come in and every one of
those patients is going to receive a
tremendously broad mix of services over
the course of a the clinic visit or
hospital state
so you literally come up with hundreds
of thousands of processes that all need
to manage and yet Kiedis which is the
main health plan level quality
measurement system us today has under a
hundred measures own you're not going to
be able to represent it instantly
measure the quality of your of health
care with 74 measures you're just not
going to do it it's it's going to be
really really skewed and what makes it
worse is the hospital's focused is
proportionally on improving their scores
on things like quitas which means that
whatever your quality score is is going
to look a lot better than you're
actually doing um but it gets worse
because out of those heaters measures
only a small portion of food of those
measures um has a significant diagnostic
component to it and if the ones with a
diagnostic amount of only a small number
have a small minority have a clinical
laboratory element to it so in there are
only nine measures in Kita's they have a
significant clinical laboratory measure
and yet for example think of all the a1c
measurements and diabetes is one of the
maintenance but we have hundreds of
laboratory tests that are used in
hundreds of different diseases and
settings now how will nine measures tell
whether we're doing a good job of making
leads or patients and the answer is that
it won't so you said sending that ACL
measures of choosing why is that there
even though it's not really a quality
measurement system that these systems
are not going to solve our need to
measure our patient and the patient
benefit of our clinical I would join
it's important to point out at this
point the patient benefit / test is not
primarily a function of the it's not
just a function of the test attributes
in other words how accurate the test is
and it's largely a function contest gets
used so the example I use here and I've
put a reference for paper that I
that I was part of studying the
cost-effectiveness appeal of the
occupied Rory chastity in that setting
he looked about your pylori we've got a
number of different lab tests available
they vary in kasnia very in accuracy and
it turns out that the patient benefit of
our own those tests and Billy some
settings is virtually the same because
in a lot of us settings doctors jump to
endoscopy so quickly in the diagnostic
algorithm the non invasive testing no
doesn't it the accuracy doesn't matter
that much that because in a lot of us
settings that there's essential grid
Deadwood sample testing by use of
endoscopy and invasive testing methods
that then it overcomes the variation of
the non-invasive tests so again the
bottom line here is if you want to look
at China under patient benefit of our
cast you have to start by looking at how
the doctors are actually using your test
and not just think in terms of the tests
own own accuracy or reliability if you
want to go from patient benefit of a
test to the total basic benefit of
testing per case really ideally really
buying guns outcomes so we'd love to
know if a more accurate you know BNP
test is going to make a difference in
heart failure outcomes or former
accurate troponin test or a different
cut off for troponin how that impacts
the outcome of mi patients the problem
is that measuring those outcomes in most
case measuring outcomes of different
diagnostic decisions or different
diagnostic tests and in most cases is
not practical because there's so many
variables in between the diagnostic test
and patient outcome that the therapeutic
decision-making really washes out in a
steady sense the measurable
impacts of the diagnostic test so
measuring outcomes it's probably love to
be able to do but it's not in be
practical in in a sort of a controlled
way to try to measure a benefit that way
and they're two other options up and I
call them the normative approach in the
manaan normative or descriptive approach
the normative approach would be simply
measure the use of our our tests against
some external benchmark such as a
guideline or expert opinion or or even
just our own sort of attempt to
summarize in clinical literature
essentially we're talking about here is
evidence-based medicine and it's a very
reasonable approach to use there are
some limitations here where I don't need
to consult our little bar problems so I
think we need to get a we need to
complement that with some non-normative
approaches as well so on the evidence
based medicine site diagnostic testing
guidelines are very useful where they
enable the main problem with them is we
don't have enough of them there are a
lot of guidelines in the world and but
they don't cover the majority of
clinical scenarios that are out there in
real world and they particularly don't
cover the majority of diagnostic
decisions and diagnostic procedures that
are available in the world one one
example of where we do have a good
guideline is for cervical cancer
screening so there's a a guy guideline
that's been out for quite some time now
I've been revised over time for cervical
cancer screening this is the ASC CP
guideline and it's a very thoughtfully
developed a guy laying in conjunction
with laboratory and obstetric gynecology
professional societies um so one thing
we can think about doing is measuring
the testing practices that we see in our
community against that guideline to see
our doctors following the guideline my
name is a useful thing to do so in our
laboratory we took a piece of that
guideline which is an HPV testing and
what kinds of HPV testing you'd expect
to see if the doctor following a
guideline um one thing that you can work
out is a testing on patients under the
age of 21 so the guideline says you
never do cervical cancer screening under
the age of 21 your good clinical and
biological reasons why it doesn't make
sense to do that under 21 so in this
histogram I show the number the
proportion of HPV tests received portion
of orders for HP be received in our
national reference laboratory for run
for patients under the age of 21 and
nations by year so in 2003 2004-2005 on
the the proportion was about thirteen
percent which is bad that means a lot of
patients under 21 we getting tested that
you know we're could be for the risk of
harm but then what you see is that
starting in about two thousand six this
proportion started to taper off what
happened was in 2006 that's when is the
first version of this guideline was
published which for the first time made
it really clear you should never be
testing at the age of 21 and so we see
here is the response by the clinical
community to that guideline now it
didn't happen immediately didn't that
portion didn't drop to zero immediately
but it did drop down over about the next
six years so it's a good news bad news
kind of a glass half-full half-empty
claiming a situation now but I'm just
using it as it really is a an
illustration of the kinds of things that
we ought to be measuring if we want to
be measuring whether we're going to get
good job by our patients another portion
of that same guideline has to do with
repeat in
impuls if you do cervical cancer
screening using the modern algorithms as
opposed to the decades-old annual pap
smear to simplified algorithm then one
of the benefits for patients is they
don't have to get tested every year and
again in this slide we show change over
time y axis is the number of months
following a negative HPV result that we
see the next HPV test are bordered and
in 2006 when the first guideline came
out the median interval with 12 months
and that interval has gone up over time
so so we see we see people following a
guideline even if it's about a hundred
percent and it's not undressing
immediate okay so um again the problem
with using guidelines as our our sole
means of measuring our patient impact is
that we don't unlike the cervical cancer
screening example for most diseases we
don't have comprehensive guidelines that
prescribe how to use all the different
diagnostic tests we have on our menus so
we need something to supplement at rest
and my proposals we supplement that with
a lot of variation measures by variation
measures were just looking at
differences in dr. practice so
measurement measurement of clinical
variation has been around for a few
decades now really starting big way at
Dartmouth with the health services
research group there some of the nice
things about measuring variation is it's
non-judgmental so if you if you go to
your clinical community and say you know
I see a four-fold variation in the
volume of BNP testing that's done in
heart failure patients is attributable
to physician variation I didn't phrase
that where you if I see a formal
difference between the doctors who
ordered them the fewest number of bmps
of their heart failure patients versus
the doctors who are the most
pees on the heart familiar patients when
you put that information out there it
doesn't imply that you have the
laboratory it doesn't need to be in a
judging mode the laboratory is just
making that information transparent but
it creates invitation from the clinical
community to have some conversations
around one and you can do this for all
of your testing the Dartmouth Atlas
website and has a lot of variation
measures on it which are really fun to
look at what I'm showing here is a
measure of overall hospital care
intensity we're using the darker colored
areas of the country tend to do a lot
more health care per capita than the
lighter colored areas of the country the
the Dartmouth Atlas group does a lot
with Medicare data and so unfortunately
they don't have a huge amount of
diagnostic variation data it publish
because it's within with claims data
it's harder to manage to run to do the
measurement on on lab tests and she
wouldn't students and drugs which are
funky here's the next two slides I'll
show some internal numbers in our
national reference lab just again just
to illustrate the concept so there are a
couple of tests out there which are sort
of like super cholesterol tests or
there's the NMR electric profile and the
the VAP cholesterol test two different
methodologies but both of them basically
correlate with with the particle with
the LDL particle number as opposed to to
lvl mass and there's some evidence out
live Utley that may correlate slightly
better with with cardiac risk there the
evidence is not clear my
these tests are ready to overtake the
inexpensive LVL measurement we do in
most rural hospitals today but I'm just
using this is it illustration variation
so again I said the two tests are are
reasonably comparable in terms of the
information we can get so in this heat
map of the United States the darker
states wonder a much higher volume of
the NMR life of profile in the light
colored states if I go to the next slide
I do the same thing with this other test
it is even two different set of states
make sure of dark so California I mean
go back California as high volume usage
of both of these tests and Montana has
low volume usage of Milton's tests but
if you look if you focus on Nevada and
Iowa Nevada is very low from da p plus
draw in Iowa is very high but Nevada is
very high for NMR life profile and I was
very love for that one so diverse so the
bottom line is this pattern looks pretty
random is there any chance this pattern
is being driven by differences in
impatience no no because your your your
cardiac risk is not going to be or the
things that you want to measure for any
at risk are not going to vary according
to these patterns what you're seeing is
positioned practice variation which is
largely driven by sales and marketing
activities by the companies that it
produces these asks so use enormous
amount of variation in physician
practices the bottom line now we can see
it in the national geographic basis here
hbu can also see it in terms of local
variation in your your local physician
of communities and it becomes a useful
thing to measure um here's another
example a very practical example of how
variation measurement can lead to
improvement a number of years ago we
identified an academic
Medical Center who was a client for a
laboratory who represented about a third
of a percent of our of our national lab
testing work overall but that
represented ninety-five percent of a
particular Carol which happened to be a
full-blood drug abuse panel it was about
70 thousand dollars a year um so a
second Santa site and it turned out it
that is so the variation the measurement
of the variation that we did to identify
this allowed it if it brought attention
to this issue which had not been on the
attention list of this hospital
laboratory prior to that and allowed
them to look into it and discovered it
isn't a process error on the part of
some of the nursing noodles and we're
ordering your mom test and and as a
result they were able to save a lot of
money and and provide better clinical
care for their patients but it was the
variation analysis which allowed us to
be discovered okay so when you're
measuring variation just a couple
thoughts you need to have reasonably
valid comparison groups that when you're
measuring for management purposes and
clinical purposes you don't have to hold
yourself to a sort of randomized control
trial or work gives control series in
the research sense is you're not
necessarily do targeting sort of
reasonable plausible validity be like
that's what I have to hold yourself to
you know publishable on science levels
of absolutely as long as you really
transparent about what you've got
benchmark is exploding multiple levels
measuring within a physician group is
extremely useful but if you can also
have benchmark against doctors across
hospitals across health systems across
geographic regions and you have a lot of
powerfulness when you do variation that
you are
make sure you're using raw volumes and
not looking at say aggregate charges or
aggregate costs because the way that
charges in costs in most hospital
systems because what we talked about
earlier are usually really really biased
and not comparable across hospitals you
know because most most laboratory
costing in hospitals based on charge
masters and there are some sort of a
modified you have your party ski
schedules I'm just going to really throw
your get introduced a lot of bias in the
system so when you want to measure
variation just colored volumes out of
your lab information system use the
wrong bell rings a testament of
information and again a low medium high
complexity approach here blessing and
fruit care would be did you know set up
a system in your laboratory of
systematically tracking variation in
ordering patterns by department and by
physician and just doing this
measurements making Republic will
actually have a big impact on your
clinical community and in sort of the
controlling a conversation about
utilization lapses comparing ordering
patterns its chemical guidelines is a
little bit harder met again we should be
doing that at least in cases such a
cervical cancer screening where we have
you no good guidelines to work with
measuring diagnostic outcomes something
that we can keep in sort of a pipedream
lab down the road I don't think that
one's going to really be feasible in the
foreseeable future ok so the care costs
become a patient benefit let's say just
a few words about quality measurement
and the the clinical diagnostic
laboratory setting we do a good job in
in clinical laboratories
of measuring quality of the test the
instrument level you know the clinical
laboratories are really good at doing
quality control and proficiency testing
and and basically putting systems in
place of the instrument level to make
sure that that we understand the
accuracy and the recluse ability of the
tests that we perform those are not the
only variables are important to the
patient into the care of the patient
turnaround time turns out to be a really
really important variable in a
value-based care environment and some
laboratories have really good systems of
measuring turnaround time across their
spectrum or laboratory tests it
typically in most settings that's done
mainly at the protest level the
opportunities that we have here are
rolling these quality measurements up
from the sort of the instrument level up
to the patient during the patient
population level so it's great that we
can do turnaround time on for test level
so we know you know what rose archer on
time distribution looked like for BNP
for example but what's really needed to
apply to some value based care setting
is we need to turn on time not from the
test respective look from the patient
perspective so for a heart failure
patient showing at the emergency room
who's decompensating do they need a BNP
well that's maybe another question but
if they do need a BMP or they certainly
will need a troponin and of a metabolic
panel let's ensure on-time in that
setting and separately what's the
turnaround time in so for an outpatient
clinic music for the same tasks so doing
it
patient perspective of the different
patient populations is where the real
power and turn around time analysis
comes in and then then you know finding
some way to roll all these quality
measures up to the overall sort of
health system level is going to be a
little bit tricky that's that's good
sort of long-term things that keep them
right and if you wanted to look at it
call it expanding your party
measurements after your clinical
laboratory I would recommend starting
with turnaround times for key diagnostic
categories so again don't if you want to
look at your true Pawnee turnaround time
don't don't just look at it as what's
what's the distribution of all of our
troponin genetics but rather split up
into emergency department critical care
units outpatient because like they're
different you're doing different
patients and different that clinical
scenarios then you know we're not ahead
with this kind of thing here at the
University of Utah our orthopedics
department has come up with a system
they call it perfect care and basically
what they did is that the orthopedist
sat down and started analyzing you know
for each each type of clinical process
that they have or let me rephrase that
it's sort of a joint replacement they
said okay if we're going to replace a
knee what would be the would be the
perfect care approach to replace it and
knee you know if everything went very
very smoothly we all the processes in
the high-quality whey and inefficient
way what about look like looks like it's
put out some to create metrics for the
nursing processes metrics for the
physician processes metrics for the
patient education processes and host
joint replacement physical therapy and
and put that on to them serving a
comprehensive management system that
they now compare themselves against and
we need now with the joint replacement
lab tests that don't play quite as big a
role as they do for relevant disease
management and care processes but this
is the sort of thing if you really want
to look at the quality of our lab we
need to get a quality or lab in the
context of what the docs are trying to
do with their patients and so it can't
be a lab alone quality measurement
system really needs to be a clinical
care quality measurement system as lab
measures mixed into it again diagnose
the outcomes are you know what we love
to do it's going to be hard to measure
this ok so again just wrapping up and
summarizing here today in healthcare
laboratories tend to have good
measurements around the the cost buckets
from a testing perspective so we know
how much you spend on reagents a year in
our lab and on which has been a labor in
our lab but the opportunities there are
to get down to cost per case again this
is the opportunity slip on the quality
side we've tended to in the clinic
laboratory to have good measurements at
the instrument level but we need to
figure out how to enroll goes up to
education level which means integrating
into larger systems of measurement that
need to be done at the clinic level and
at the hospital level then in terms of
how to how to our lab tests benefit the
patient which is really most important
category this is also the category of
the least robust measures available
today and we need to put the most effort
into developing these and we need to
think in terms of benefit per case where
we use guidelines for Bay
herbal but we're not available where we
we we have systematic process of
measuring variation once we we get a
reasonable systems in place to measure
laboratory diagnostic benefit at the
case level then we can begin to think
about rolling listings up to overall
quality measures in the hospital so that
we can say yes our laboratory has gotten
fifty percent better at producing good
patient outcomes there were ten years
ago well today we absolutely would have
no basis for making a claim like that
but if we if we start by doing the
benefit / case precast level we may be
able to come up with at least some sense
of whether we're going in the right
direction at the general population
level so you know where where does all
heads over the long run and the
importance of all of this is going from
a laboratory centric perspective on
laboratory medicine to a medicine etc
which like you from laboratory medicine
because inner long run what really
counts and in terms of what we really
want to be measuring and thinking that
measurement measuring is the impact that
happens at the medicine end of things
and what we do in the laboratory is
really really important that it's
important is immense to the end so that
our eyes need to focus more on the
medicine side of things over the long
run and not just on the laboratory side
and so with that that concludes my my
presentation for today and I am
available for a few minutes if there are
any questions
thank you dr. Jackson for your
presentation quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Jackson will answer as many
questions as time permits and the first
question is what you see is the role of
payers in this sort of system should
they be a major player in measurement of
clinical diagnostics ok so the role of
hairs they didn't really talk about that
payers in my presentation pairs are
interesting in that historically at
pairs had a lot of data that wasn't
necessarily available at the clinical
enterprise level so it's not a
coincidence that one of the first sort
of national level clinical quality
measurement systems was kitas which is a
measurement of Health Plan data well the
problem with the hair side is that pairs
are disconnected from the clinical
enterprise so the data that that the
payers have on is is distorted by the by
the measurement systems and in pairs
even more importantly don't have good
management techniques to provide
feedback loops into improving clinical
care now some of you may challenge that
and you can say well what about
something a pre-authorization I'm in our
health care system there's a lot of
preauthorization that goes on and as an
attempt to to enforce and promote
cost-effectiveness and any clinician
will tell you preauthorization is
horrible in from the clinical
perspective because it's just incredibly
inefficient hairs are not at the front
lines clinical care they they can't
produce at nuance patients sensitive
judgment calls in turn
of resource utilization so forth so if
we're going to really manage clinical
care properly we need to be doing it at
the patient level not you know at the
50,000 foot level of repair so so
honestly my bottom line is I don't see a
really important role of hairs long term
in quality measurement and certainly I
don't see well four pairs of quality
management this is something that the
hospitals and clinics need to take
responsibility for and not not relegate
that to it hair site health labs in
general started using big data methods
leveraged across a region or network or
our lab environments so different that
the data would be too noisy okay
interesting question and big data is a
really hot topic in the business wrong
tonight and yes big date and all data is
noisy and and data scientists that work
with big data know that all data is
noisy but there are ways to to normalize
and standardizing and clean data to come
to release useful useful results so just
for example if if we were to look at
variation analysis for laboratory tests
if yours is if you were to use and there
are consultants out there to do this so
I'm not about imagining the scenario if
you are to you look if you were to
benchmark laboratories against each
other in terms of total lab spend using
a charge master level data and again
there are consultants will go out and do
this on that kind of thing is going to
be incredibly noisy and you're basically
garbage in garbage out you're not going
to get the useful results and you get
really misleading results on the other
hand
fewer do you do benchmarking across
clinical enterprises using raw order
volume data and if you made sure that
your denominators were reliable and
transparent so if you had say yo turtle
number of you know BNP's you know her
heart failure patient per year and and
measure that in salt lake city vs. New
York City that kind of a the comparison
would have faced validity so yeah I see
a lot of opportunity for forgoing much
bigger on the inside and I'm I'm pretty
optimistic there if we're careful about
it there are ways to deal with the
heterogeneity it's not trivial but their
ways to deal with it how would you
evaluate the value of a new diagnostic
test that currently is not being tested
for okay that that one is a really
important question and this deals with
you know when when tests come onto the
market this is a really important
question what's what's the value of that
test the problem is we really don't know
at that point on I you know an ideal
idealized scenario might be if new
diagnostic tests went through massive
clinical trials before coming onto the
market that's what we do with with new
drugs for example you betta totaling a
drug in order to get through the FDA you
have to do massive of your randomized
clinical trials and get at least some
sense of the you know this is an FDA
language but basically the patient
benefit for that you drunk that doesn't
happen in the lab and frankly it's it's
not ever going to happen a lot because
it's not practical massive clinical
trials are really really expensive
and it would add to the cost
inflammatory custom what we need to do
is come up with better ways of measuring
the value in the course of actual
clinical practice I think disease
registries have some potential to do
this for example if you look at it the
kind of work in cystic fibrosis
foundation was done over the decades
improving cystic fibrosis kare 11 aspect
of cystic fibrosis care that his
improves over time by being studied and
systematically worked on on is the
diagnostic side you know what do you
culture in these CF kids how do you
culture them having standardized those
responses easier these are improvements
that were made with the support of the
systematic data collection which happens
to the Cystic Fibrosis Foundation and in
related areas um so I i think the the
goal is we need to set up systems to
really tune to measure what's going on
first of all in routine clinical care
and the component of the laboratory
component of that and then we can go
back and try to estimate the benefit
side of it it's not easy and when when
you test new technologies come out now
my definition we don't know when it was
any real benefit divisions because when
new tests come out basically what we
have is some sort of first principles
argument about how it's better we say
well this new cholesterol test you know
it's going to be a more accurate in
cardiac risk because of XYZ but we don't
have that level as an actual clinical
trial that shows the decision-making by
the doctors is is chained
good enough in a significant enough
level and direction Don to actually
produce better outcomes so it's a hard
one the bottom line is it's really hard
to measure out outcome and but the only
practical way to do it in most cases is
by measuring the use measuring what goes
on in actual clinical care as opposed to
expensive clinical trials because the
expense of clinical trials usually don't
happen is there a link between a
laboratory measurement and a particular
medicine um II in many cases yes um so I
think the question is getting to the
yeah you're sort of a you know a new
obviously right how to best place in the
context in I think we from the
laboratory side and I think I think we
need to think much more in terms of how
do our tests change clinical decision
making the link is a human link that's
important to recognize if we have a test
that tells you that drug a is going to
be better than drug B it doesn't
automatically mean that doctors you're
getting nudes drug a run the test is
positive Rutland rugby it just means
this potential to influence the choice
of the drug so it's a human link and we
need to be really sensitive to them
oncologists for example tend to be much
more sensitive or much more pay much
more attention to lab tests that tell
them that they can use a particular
chemotherapy to treat my patient and at
colleges pay less relatively less
attention to left
tell them that they don't need to use a
particular chemotherapy that may sound
like a subtle difference but it's
actually really important for the
patient perspective we need to be we
need to not automatically think that
that all of our lab tests are being
reused are being linked is tightly to
therapeutic incisions as easily as they
potentially compete I'm not sure that's
really writer the question was it can to
go without anything else he's important
for me i would like to once again thank
dr. Jackson for his presentation do you
have any final comments today dr.
Jackson I know other than you know
really appreciate the opportunity to
talk about a topic but i think is going
to be at one of increasing importance in
your healthcare world i would also like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provide it at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through may 12 2016 lab roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye